in micro ich bin ich scheiße in
minecraft das ist voll gemein ich bin
nicht heißt in minecraft jetzt findet er
mich weil ich gesagt habe
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge heute spielen wir jump
league und ihr merkt schon
der hintergrund sieht anders aus das
liegt daran dass ich jetzt gerade in
berlin aufnehmen
ich bin hier untergekommen beim li und
in habt ihr vielleicht schon meine leute
das war eine kiste hätte sie noch diese
länder partikel doch ich wurde dass der
küste wo denn finde ich find ich bin bei
ihren untergekommen er hatte schon
meinen blog von mir gesehen vielleicht
eventuell das ist einfach ende partikel
aber ist okay dann ist eben keine lust
oder alles klar dann geht es weiter so
ich bin heute umgezogen und heute der
zehn mal so ein bisschen was über meinen
umzug und die allgemeine lage in
situation heute in berlin
es ist jetzt gerade 00 43 mittlerweile
der vierzehnte und später am heutigen
tage das heißt montag als die nacht von
sonntag auf montag und mord montag früh
beginnt mein erster tag im praktikum da
bin ich schon ziemlich gespannt so
gespannt dass ich kein minecraft man
spielen kann
ja aber fangen wir an wie habe ich
gemacht ursprünglich wollte ich am 12
nach berlin fahren und dann noch am 13
tag haben um die buren noch wissen
sauber zu machen bevor ich da ein ziel
haben wir hier so kurz mal reingucken
das hat soweit funktioniert nur wollte
ich halt am 12
idealerweise mittags um vielleicht um
vier in berlin sein also sind von mir
aus fünf stunden fahrt das lief nicht so
wie geplant am ende bin ich weil ich
noch tausend sachen machen musste ich ja
zum parken verdeckt ich kann etwas
überhaupt nicht so auf eine gewisse
deadline gerade wenn es um reisen geht
hin arbeiten weil ich dann immer noch
das und das einpacken muss man hier und
da an so funktioniert einfach nicht bei
mir also bin ich dann am ende dann also
bin ich dann am ende um halb elf nachts
los gefahren also sag mal satte 60
stunden später und das war eine relativ
knackige autofahrt ich habe fünf statt
nach berlin gebraucht
man hat mein auto randvoll gepackt also
ich habe ein recht kleines auto das
wisst ihr vielleicht ich habe das
randvoll gepackt und bin da mit nach
berlin gefahren ich habe wirklich
gehofft dass mich niemand anhält weil
locker hätten sie mich dafür schießen
können für die art und weise über ein
auto geparkt war
tatsächlich könnte nachschauen steht im
detail date.de dld deutsch lernen
da kann man das nachschauen wer öfters
mal weg alles klar so ja und dann kam
ich nachts um vier in berlin an
und wir machen neuer mitbewohner hat
sind wir erst mal gefreut so dass er
nachts um vier darstellen durfte und wir
tragen helfen durfte mit meinen sachen
da war aber sehr freundlich und dann
haben wir am 13
dann auch diese blöcke sind so geil aus
am 13
dass das thema noch bisschen geputzt du
bist gerade eben das hat sich auch
länger heraus gezögert als gedacht dann
haben wir sushi gegessen auf dem balkon
draußen das war ultra lecker mit julia
die auch noch hier ist die kammer noch
zum helfen richtig nett von ihren banken
die ist nämlich auch hier oben zum
jubilieren ist auch im zimmer na klar
diese stehen alle die stehen hinter mir
und machen komische gesten und bringen
mich in verlegenheit und ich heiß aber
mullin game und alle leute gehen darum
geht aus der runde raus ständig gewinn
nicht ständig glück ja direkt zu mir am
ende gewinne ich die runde ohne zu zu
fighten im deathmatch soja und dann wie
gesagt gestern abend fünf angekommen
dann habe ich das gröbste gepackt haben
eine matratze hier bezogen habe ich da
hingelegt und habe sehr wenig geschlafen
dann heute morgen also von ich bin so
einem 6 eigentlich schlafen oder so ich
mein wenn ich im 4 ankomme noch
auspacken und dann erstmal hier bis in
die bude anschaut kann ahnung alles
mögliche machen
wisst ihr wie es ist wenn man umzieht
oder vielleicht auch nicht
auf jeden fall ist es sehr spannend das
kann man schon mal sagen ja dann bin ich
um halb sieben eingeschlafen heute
morgen um halb zwölf aufgestanden also
fünf stunden dann sind wir erstmal los
gezogen haben uns frühstück geholt und
da habe ich schon
direkt sonne relativ meisten situationen
gehabt
wir sind hin und her geschlendert in
irgendeinem von den 20010 was die flora
von keats bitte in die kommentare
schreiben
kita kids dann aber der flora von kw 112
ps oder okay wir sind auf dem kiez auf
den verschiedenen kiez rumgelaufen und
dann haben uns ohne eine bäckerei
ausgesuchtem typische haben uns ein
bisschen zurückgeholt café latte
macchiato und weil wir hat die gangster
den latte macchiato trinken so im knast
und ja da haben wir unser leben gesteht
uns war vorne ein wunderschönes setting
also draußen zu sitzen
da habe ich dazu die zeit in berlin
beginnt wirklich sehr angenehm
ob da jetzt runter so ja danach haben
wir dann julia vom bahnhof abgeholt die
kam
ich weiß ja nie kann man da drauf
springen um halb vier kannte halb vier
seit die stimme aus dem off vier extra
viva musica um halb vier in berlin an
wir werden so ungefähr um 4 am zob weil
wir ja unsere abfahrt ein bisschen
versteckt haben und weil wir hier auch
noch bisschen was aber nicht gemacht
hätten im staub gesaugt sehr schön
erst mal runterfallen ist immer
entspannt also dann waren wir eine halbe
stunde warten lassen wie sich das gehört
für gentlemen und dann haben wir haben
wir die eingelesen und so weiter die
buden haben da erstmal so fünf sechs
stunden lang geputzt und haben jetzt so
ein zimmer halb fertig aber es geht auf
jeden fall voran
wir haben nicht bei weitem nicht die
ganze bude fertig bekommen aber ich muss
alles schon ganz ganz cool und ganz neu
ist hier ein problem ist dass meine
windows jetzt gerade eben noch mal schön
also man 100 gezehrt schön herum
gesponnen meinte irgendwie dass der
minecraft lounge ein virus ist so und
dann ging der spaß los und wie wir im
programm also sind die denken denn sie
haben recht und deinstallieren seine
leute einfach du kannst dagegen nichts
machen so und dann war die frage ist der
minecraft verwirklichen virus wurde die
website vielleicht gehackt und dann hat
mich darauf gebracht dass java
vielleicht das problem ist also javadi
installiert installiert nix dann
minecraft neunstadt 20.000 mal die
installiert wieder installiert auch
nichts und dann sowie dahinter gekommen
dass vielleicht mal ein anti viren
programm einfach scheiße ist und wir
hinter behämmert politisch korrekten so
hatte haye ich traue ich eindringlich
ich muss dafür durchlaufen und da haben
wir einfach mal gedacht okay dann
zweimal das pferd vom fuß auf und haben
gesagt okay dann den zunehmend einfach
mal das wie ein programm wenn das sagt
das ist ein virus und tada dann erfasst
installiert und was sagt ja alles gute
der mainkofener ist kein wie horst die
salzburger scheiße gebaut
es hat so gesagt den sprachnachrichten
hier kein witz dass das programm redet
übrigens wirklich also meinst also hey
willkommen zu avastin mit meinen
antivirenprogramm jetzt mir das willst
einfach die viren von mein pc fernhalten
und dann denkt machen und die schnauze
halten ja ich hab die leute ich habe
zehn pfund 3 anschaulicher es ist nicht
auszuhalten dass er gut wird das aber
viel zu gut so und ich glaube dass hier
das letzte modul kann das sein
der entscheid wird auf jeden fall er
wird vielleicht nicht allzu in balance
aber kann ich bitte vielleicht noch
finde schon dass wir einfach traumhaft
konzentrieren kurz konzentrieren
kurz mal dilaver maschine ausstellen ok
und so und so oh ja wir kommen näher als
ein ekliger nein wahrscheinlich mit
fakten wir einfach keine entspannte egal
jetzt schnell die magic box raus dollar
1 2 und 3 vielleicht hat irgendjemand
ihren entscheid mit table an homo 10 uhr
am meego kick back on the go morgen um
10 uhr beginnt also ihr seht das video
am montag und an diesem montag begann um
10 uhr morgens mein praktikum übrigens
sehr coole arbeitszeit eigentlich 10 uhr
morgens arbeitsbeginn damit könnt mich
anfreunden
ich bin nämlich überhaupt kein
frühaufsteher vorher in den letzten
tagen als ich aber semester vernarrte
habe ich alles gemacht aber sicher nicht
umhin sich ja nicht macht ausstatten
ich hasse das was man immer eingekeilt
zwischen aber was du hast dich ab 10
pfeile
hier kriegt die alle rein von mir leid
dass ich jetzt umbringen sollen nämlich
oder nicht wo ich mir nicht hallo hallo
leute ich komme auf jeden fall nicht der
wahl verlieren nicht zu erreichen
normalerweise haben auf jumping
eigentlich eine relativ gute range of
stichwort range thema ranger muss ich an
die internetleitung denken dies will
endlich auch richtig gut nicht so gut
wie bei uns in wo wir einfach 153 ab
haben durch unsere op glasfaser aber
hier immerhin auch mal 100 down und aber
noch nicht es steht nun frei weg ja es
da auch erst dann ist auch sehr schön
nicht so viel aber immerhin 10 ab laut
glaube ich 119 ab damit kann ich auch
anfreunden und das heißt auch dass wir
hier sehr schön streamen können
da freue ich mich auch login vorder wird
dieses gold looking forward wie der
wiederbeginn von dem buch erste was ich
mein konto sondern rein so ja jetzt ist
es zehn vereinsleute ich habs gerade
eben schon mal kurz angedeutet ich muss
morgen um 8 antanzen
die nacht wird so doch bisschen kürzer
sie mir vorgestellt hatte ich wollte
nämlich eigentlich um 12 uhr schlafen
gehen dann bis 88 stunden
das hat natürlich nicht funktioniert
weil es einfach niemals funktioniert
finde ich sage ich ihm zuvor ins bett
und schlafe acht stunden nicht wenn ich
nur irgendwas erledigen muss zumal da
business flat bis zu lange putts dann
rum gechillt und am ende wird so
ungefähr halb zwei er 272 einschlafen
und morgens sechs stunden gehen gut die
letzte nacht war auch nicht allzu lang
aber das wird schon gehen ich hole mal
von morgen einen zehnfachen espresso
passt das motto der gegner ist glaube
ich unter mir ich hab noch diesen
eigenen danken gegner der nicht ganz
gerne wegklatschen
vielleicht hier nein muss diese menschen
besser ja sehr schön frontal in die
fresse habe ich in der werke klatscht
habe ich besseres equipment als er habe
auf jeden fall hat er noch ein leben und
es sieht so aus als würde ich
tatsächlich mal wieder eine runde jump
league gewinnen
nach langer langer zeit haben wir das
geschafft übrigens leon und julia sind
einfach im hintergrund gerade so die
ganze also richtig peinlich am schweigen
ich weiß genau was sie da sitzen mir zu
hören war seltsam
ja ich mache sie für mich lustig in
minecraft ich bin ich scheiße minecraft
das ist voll gemein ich bin nicht in
minecraft aber jetzt findet er mich weil
ich gesagt hab aber egal ich kann nichts
bäumchen zu erleben der hat nur noch ein
leben und ich hole mir denn jetzt kommen
the legend of the legend de absolute bvb
legende unbesiegt jetzt wo man trotzdem
kommt usa ist nicht immer so richtig
freudig aber was ist freudig der macht
eigentlich also der nimmt mir jetzt
nicht noch ein leben ab wirklich nicht
ok kleiner lag weil das texture pack
besteht so groß wie ein pc ist ja so
jetzt
n-joy wunderbar der scc tag das was von
heutigen folge leute so bisschen die
geschichte von meinem umzug
ich werde aber jetzt immer versuchen für
euch abends aufzunehmen dann für den
nächsten tag vor zu produzieren weil
sonst keine videos kommen können weil
ich von 10 bis 18 uhr arbeite ja alle
berliner zuschauer schreibt irgendwie
coolen sachen rein macht vorschläge
keine ahnung maske